[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I swear my creative process works so
last-minute I don't know I don't know
why but they're always just seems to be
like one moment where I wake up at like
5:00 in the morning and I have this
brand new idea that's amazing so I've
got two weeks left now to my deadline
just under my thought now is if I try
and get the game kind of polished
running it's lagging at the moment cuz
I've got way too much stuff in that I
haven't baked any lights yeah and it's
just like magic
nothing so if I do that now now this
week then that gives me a whole nother
week to maybe add a little something
extra because I was thinking I want to
make it more personal but obviously not
using the Facebook SDK anymore
I don't know in my mind it's video me so
why don't I use a webcam and I can still
put a prompt to perform be like best to
use if you have a webcam whatever I can
insert their their pictures I could even
have a real time display and it's like a
security camera and it's them looking
themselves or if they peep in the door
on the way back through the hallway
maybe they just saw themselves like play
in the game but what is just something
symbols less is more less is more anyway
that's my ideas but now I need to go to
uni get all the sewage I'm gonna I'm
gonna get this done when I get in these
moods I'm like it will be done and I put
everything on my calendar and I just
like plan out my days but anyway yeah
gotta go gotta go
breaking oh oh you don't real good how's
the other hand yeah I just done that on
you side it's most annoying thing when
you move in the rig
you got to do it from in oh yeah yeah it
worked oh my gosh we didn't even get to
use our rig because we just use the
Maxima rig took like what does this look
like before though like was it just
white and then we put all the details in
just like yes oh good line bits are
already white and the rim is already
white because I I create the textures
first and then so with the things like
the walls I already got a premade normal
because yeah but then you've got it like
look I'll call the reflection probe
looks yeah it properly just gets the
whole room and just
the sun is shining but it's another day
working on the game whoo it's a little
bit stressful today so I had like these
grand plans like I always do
I'm just adding more things into the
game like everyone a tap into the webcam
and then I found this it's my eye
tracker and it's got a unity SDK and I
was like oh my god I want to play but
then I started to play the game
yesterday and we're trying to do like
baking things and it's just it's so
laggy like I put so much into the game
which is so weird because I show people
and they're like doesn't see what that
much is happening but because it's like
a walkthrough game it's kind of um it's
checking like what you're doing and it's
making presumptions of you so it's like
constantly like checking a lot of stuff
is in the update which is really bad so
I didn't go through all my code try and
make it cleaner try and not put things
in the update loop because that's
basically checking two things every
freaking frame and that's probably why
it's crushing also I need to make
another intro scene because I've got
this animation bit at the beginning but
it's all in the same scene so I'm
thinking if I can just make a little
interesting
then that'd be good what else am i doing
it's so weird I baked lights and I add
did reflection probes and my materials
have just gone great so I need to turn
them from standard to diffuse because
diffuse work fine so I'll just do that
but yeah I don't think I'll be able to
add in all the cool stuff Navas
deadlines way me I don't know I'll see
I'd like to but like I can play with it
afterwards after my deadline
it would just be cool if I could have it
for my deadline but ya know we'll see
but this is my day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is now the evening I don't really
know how these vlogs are gonna work out
I'm sure I will show you some more
screen grabs like along the way but I
guess this is just for you to see how I
work as well
it is 3:14 at the moment and I have been
working since the morning but like once
you get into it you just get into it and
especially one of my top tips if you
want to be productive is make yourself a
list like I like to write it down a
physical list on a piece of paper and
then just like tick everything off bit
by bit and you feel so good about
yourself or it does the opposite because
I had 12 things to do today and I did
seven of them but at the same time I
look at this and I'm like that's over
halfway so yeah so I got through
tomorrow but it's time for bed I think
as you know I'm making a belt just to
see how it how it runs in the bill that
I'm like super scared that is not even
gonna run I'm like ah look at it it's a
working it's working okay well I can't I
shouldn't speak too soon my animations
they run so slowly in the unity editor
okay cuz they're ready hi Polly like I
had to meet him so locally a little bit
the monster get them brothers dead and
she's just like sure your screen you
fella this but look how cool freak rupee
he is creepy
oh no he's got headaches guys it's got a
headache now he's gone but don't worry
it's another beautiful way and I've got
a code again oh my gosh Wow um anyway
yesterday I managed to get the lag down
like a bunch it was so good
occlusion culling not putting my code in
the update as much what else made a
massive difference
oh yeah instantiating prefabs and making
a separate scene for my animation at the
beginning so did all that yesterday and
now today I'm going to be playing around
with the lights making it look pretty
baking some of them I'm gonna leave a
lot of them to be real-time though
because they're gonna be like flickering
and turning on off and stuff but the lag
is pretty much gone now and I'm so so
happy so yeah let's just
oh no it's okay okay don't have to look
100% okay all the time on YouTube okay
right yeah let's get men's work
[Music]
I'm so tired I have my little list my
little to do no this is my bulb to do
list how am i need to do list and I'm
gonna try and take off at least two
things before I allow myself to have
breakfast and a shower because that's
how I work I restrict myself and then I
reward myself so I get coded
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just wanna say my housemates are the
freakin Judas cuz I'm here just do my
code and they are having a barbecue so
they brought me a cocktail maybe maybe
we'll go out and say hi to them in a bit
I feel like this love is just gonna be
like me on my chair me over check me on
my chair again me that's fine I am
working I swear I look a bit more alive
now because I've gotten to the game to
kind of like a state where well no let's
do it okay but I feel like I've done not
enough for the day but enough to allow
myself a break because you need breaks
so the game is playable all the way
through to the end now and you can go
back to the menu after you finish oh my
god what achievement and still looks
dreadful though so I still need to have
us full day I mean I gotta put audio in
and I gotta make it look pretty but the
other code it's done there's no lagging
there's no crashing oh I'm so happy
umm also top tips to keep yourself
motivated when you're working I was just
thinking about this cuz I was just doing
himself I was getting ready annoying I
was like hmm so I've got some socks that
I really like
because I love bananas and I just
finally like the small things that make
all the difference when you're super
super stressed but yeah now I'm gonna go
take a little break see my house means
they've been outside having a little
barbecue drinking and whatnot so I'll
say hi my game runs through to the end
[Music]
does it [ __ ] wag all the way we ate
the food know that I'm leaving the
broccoli oh hello how are you referring
you enjoying the Sun what's your
favorite part about yes-men she could
sing my favorite party buddy has been
the fish she can sing and then she's
like every lovely lady personally she's
kind she's beautiful as well she's so
beautiful she needs to hear this more
Jerry green that is very true
we'll see yeah Gwinnett's like 10th
level
[Music]
[Applause]
yo girl with Yacktman eggs super
relaxing session of yoga with your
special hose yog Mannix I think I've
already seen likes said that and known
for and I don't know how to speak
English I'm sorry yes man you can cut
this out for me to me I don't know
whatever you choose but you amps
together you're ready to play that's
what she said we're ready to play yes oh
yes means playing look at the air it's
just beat up and she's Peeta peace it
looks like you holding hands
that's so cute ah oh my god there's a
bug in your camera yes means
[Music]
how do you feel after teaching yoga I
feel so good came late to like yoga with
the egg Mannix education
[Music]
[Music]